hello and welcome to another video today
we're going to be talking about blame a
sci-fi cult classic amongst the manga
community we'll cover all the major plot
points that transpire within the 1 hour
and 45 minutes of this film this film
isn't half bad despite being cgi and it
can be seen as an alternate story
compared to what happens in the manga so
don't worry about spoilers either
alright then should we begin the story
takes place far into the future where
everyday life as we know it has
completely done of 180. civilization has
evolved in fact it's reached its
ultimate form the net terminal form the
technology has evolved beyond what was
once conceivable however an accident or
should i say an infection in the past
caused all the automated systems to
malfunction
they all went out of control and the
very technology that had done so much
for civilization now became the greatest
threat to its existence the multi-level
city structures begin to replicate
themselves indefinitely in all
directions the city started resembling
what you can refer to as a matrix
now why is this detrimental to
civilization well because of the
infection humans no longer have access
to the control systems the defense
systems called safeguard is on steroids
and is actively hunting down all humans
in the middle of this catastrophic
situation there's a village where humans
are gradually starting to see their
eventual extinction not only are they
trapped because of the defense system
the food supplies are also fleeting so
it's a nightmare seeing how they've not
got many options a young girl named zuru
and a few of her friends set out on the
pursuit to discover some food for
themselves in their village their
pursuit is fueled by despair
unfortunately a watchtower notices them
and they accidentally end up alerting
the safeguard system the automated
machines instantly flood the scene and
start attacking them left and right the
situation isn't looking good for them
many lose their life but before the
machines could take out zuru a
mysterious yet strong individual shows
up he exhibits a fine display of
strength and cleanly exterminates the
defense units present at the scene
before zuru and her friends could thank
him properly he firmly states that he
just wants to see their eyes just for
context they were equipped with full
body defense suits zuru's flustered but
she shows him her eyes
his body is equipped with some sort of
scouting device which helps him see if a
human has the net terminal gene or not
sadly neither zuru nor her other two
friends have it though since he saved
their lives zuru and her friends decide
to accompany him back to the village
considering how one of the grown-ups
might know something about the net
terminal gene the guy is already on his
way by this point zuru tells him to wait
and then asks him what are you to which
the guy replies i am keeley as they're
on their way back zuru tells him that
their village is in a place where the
defense system can't get to for some
unknown reason when they get there a few
individuals at the entrance ask him
where he came from to which he replied
that he came from 6 000 levels below
this layer now while the skepticism is
there they take him inside the village
so they can talk properly in the village
everyone's devastated after learning
what happened to everyone else keeley on
the other hand observes these humans
using his scouter apparently none of
them have got the gene that he's looking
for though he also realizes that most of
them are malnourished a young girl
reaches out to him and he silently
brings something out of his pocket and
hands it to her it's a kind of processed
food that expands exponentially once
thrown into the water so everyone eats
and rejoices
later they have a talk with keely he
briefly explains that he came from
thousands of levels below the city or
for the sake of finding someone who has
the net terminal gene because it's only
when he discovers someone with this gene
that the civilization would finally be
able to regain control over the enhanced
artificial intelligence and shut down
the menacing safeguard defense system
this obviously surprises everyone but
their leader then remembers that he
heard about the net terminal gene a long
time ago he also refers to a place
inside their parameter which they aren't
supposed to go to or so their ancestors
have always told them it's the rotting
shrine and once kelly hears about this
he immediately gets up and starts
approaching the shrine the leader zuru
and her friend accompany him
there they witness an unstable hologram
apparently it's projecting out of a
corpse-like robot of a woman named sibo
she talks and says that she's been
waiting for 17 million
526 000 hours as for her intro she's a
scientist from a time before this
infection happened and civilization was
driven into a corner keeley wonders if
she has the net terminal jeans but she
says of course not however she reveals
some interesting pieces of information
it's because of a shield she created
that this place has forever remained
free of the safeguard defense system not
only that if keeley can take her 15
blocks away to an automated factory she
can get them rations and also create a
synthetic terminal that'll have the same
effect as that of the net terminal gene
the journey to that automated factory
would have taken them more than a couple
of days
and since if the experiment succeeded
the village would have benefited greatly
the leader assembles a group of
experienced folks to accompany killi
zuru and thai are amongst the group
members and so the journey begins they
stop they eat except keely he doesn't
need to eat food after a couple of days
worth of hustle of hiding from the
safeguard the guys finally reached the
desired automated factory once there
sibo helps operate the system she logs
in and instantly locates a substantial
supply of rations for the village the
folks now have food that will probably
last a while but the plan doesn't go as
smoothly as it could have sibo makes a
gadget for keely but right when she
tries to log out of the system something
triggers a reaction from the safeguard
suddenly an insane number of
exterminators pop up they're here to
exterminate the intruders she quickly
uses the system and creates a cyborg
form from her body and then with the
help of a railway car everyone gets back
to the village there was a big
confrontation with the exterminators
many lose their lives while keeley went
above and beyond in trying to save as
many as he could dare lost her arm and
after all the fighting keeley was
knocked unconscious
now that they're back at the village
keeley is given a proper space to rest
he still hasn't regained his
consciousness meanwhile the entire
village celebrates the incredible amount
of food rations that they've secured
though it was also a moment of grief and
silence considering how many of them
lost their lives during this pursuit and
all the ones before it so in order to
mourn the loss the village leaders
ordered to turn off the lights and let
everyone have a moment of silence for
all those who have lost their lives
until now
kili is lying in his chamber zuru pays
him a visit and starts wondering about
what keeley will be doing from here on
out siba also enters the room she makes
him come back to his consciousness and
then takes him down to the shield
generator though at that point something
unexpected happened zuru's dear friend
daai gets to the observatory and then
using her gun she shoots the shield
generator this in turn alerts the
safeguard system though why would she do
such a thing to all of her people well
as it turns out the real thai had died
during the confrontation with the
exterminators the one who accompanied
them back was a fake one sent by the
safeguard system soon enough she takes
on her real appearance considers
everyone an illegal resident and thus
begins to shoot them all dead it's just
a disaster and like that the final act
of this film begins meanwhile sibo
continues to the shield generator keeley
rushes back to the scene to help the
villagers
there he sees the cyborg just straight
up killing the villagers left and right
those in charge lead everyone else to
the top of the village so that they can
counter her attacks using their weapons
and turn this into a long distance deal
though as keeley is finally at the scene
he enters mortal combat with the cyborg
it is a close fight she knocks him down
but during the exchanges she also knows
the keeley's body was originally from
the safeguard meaning it was stolen
meanwhile sibo was done setting up the
machine and she connects herself to it
cyborg notices and points a gun at her
fortunately though one of the villagers
shoots at her and she misses the shot
sibo loses one of her arms but she's
still conscious throughout by taking
this opportunity our dear zuru throws
kilia gun which he then uses to
exterminate the cyborg once and for all
the veteran scientist isn't done yet
though in the virtual realm she engages
in a conversation with the control
system of the safeguard the idea was to
simply request it to let the villagers
go she knew now that the shield is
broken more and more safeguard
exterminators will keep raiding the
village but the control system didn't
oblige although sibo did get access to
the city's ever-changing map it allowed
her to see which exactly would be the
best place for the village to
re-establish itself as it turns out
there was an abandoned level a couple of
layers beneath their level it's safe
from the safeguard and their best option
is to just escape there and re-establish
themselves she uses her abilities to
lead the villagers to the abandoned
level using a railway car but right
before they can get there a watchtower
lays its eye on them yet again it
instantly sends a humongous exterminator
kili gives the exterminator stealth
gadget to zuru tells them that he'll
keep trying to find the net terminal
gene and then silently bids them
farewell
while they get to the abandoned level he
engages in combat with the exterminator
to put it simply he seemingly sacrifices
himself to save them in the epilogue of
the film there's a young girl
reminiscing about this story she talks
as the visuals show a village prospering
within that abandoned level she is
zuru's granddaughter and obviously she
always shared keeley's stories with her
granddaughter and now as her
granddaughter holds the gadget she
wonders or rather she believes the
keeley is still out there searching for
the net terminal gene
then we see keeley walking and searching
as always
at that point
the movie ends right there and then the
film appears to be a side quest when
compared with the manga but it is still
enjoyable it can serve as a nice
introduction to anyone who wants to
experience this series now what did you
think of the story did you like it are
you planning on watching it or have you
watched it already share your thoughts
in the comments section down below i'm
always looking forward to hearing them
well then i'll see you in the next video